hello everyone we have a very exciting
in the wild game from the Charlotte
International Chess Championship Cup for
women it's played between a Polish
international master Karina Tchaikovsky
and women grandmaster Zainab Mahmud II
era of Azerbaijan now I've been
strolling through the internet as I
usually do and I saw this photo of
Karina shipkov Scott not this photo it's
the one from the thumbnail David Lara
posted it on Twitter with her position
that she currently has on the board
saying that ship Costa is probably
currently creating her immortal game so
I was interested what the game was about
but I couldn't find the game so that
would send it to me and it's a really an
interesting game I mean it's not it's
not lost curse king hunter against the
Dutch but again a wonderful attack
against the Dutch defense so let's see
this game we have d4 by Karina and f5 by
design zeyneb the Dutch defense g3 the
fianchetto attack to the Dutch defense
Knight f6 Bishop g2 g 6 now knife to h3
Bishop g7 and to Knight to f4 preparing
h4 h5 zeyneb castles we had h4 and e 6
and since black didn't really do
anything to stop White's plan Carina
simply pushes forward with the plant h5
and here probably the only good idea for
black here is to push g5 so after g5 and
h6 the Bishop h8 a knight back to h3
with a double attack on the g5 pawn g4 9
f4 md5 it's a it's a better position for
a while but it's it's playable for black
you know you have to play precisely on
both sides to gain anything from the
position but after h5 Zena played Queen
to e8 so H captures on g6 was played
each characters on g6 and now see for
preventing black black from executing d5
Queen to f7 adding pressure to be five
nights e3 now adding another defender to
the d5 square and rook to e8 we have III
c6 now and d5 now completely not
allowing black to
push d5e five kicking the night away in
Knight to h3 and now II for Knight to g5
would attempt on the Queen Queen e7 and
now d6 Queen d8 and here c5 was played
and if you look at this position this is
this is this is a catastrophe for black
it's not white doesn't really have any
any clean execute but look at those
pieces there and these pawns seats e5
and e6 are just beautiful right to e5
trying to develop some pieces and also
maybe maybe trying to get this Knight to
d5 to to at least activate somehow but
Queen to b3 check Knight to d5 and here
we have f4 and what do you play here
well you could play he captures on f3 um
poisson but if he captures on f3 then
knife chapters on f3 going for the rook
only movies rook to e6 you have to block
Czech Knight captures pawn captures and
after Queen captures it's simply a
terrible position for black the rookie
spin night is coming to g5 this Bishop
can come to thee to c3 pressure the
bishop and g7 that's a basically a
winning position for white
so after f4 mama di rogga decided to
devise a devious plan she played nice to
a6 she decided to give up a whole rope
here on e5 what's the idea that after
Knight captures pawn on c5 who would
attack on the Queen the Queen doesn't
have a good square but you'll see what I
mean
Karina accepted the rook F captures on
e5 was played Knight captures on c5 and
here you have to be extremely careful
the Queen doesn't really have a lot of
squares if you play Queen before you get
93 check for King the king and the Queen
you'll lose the Queen and the game on
the other hand after Knight captures on
c5 if you play something like Queen to
a3 then comes Knight to d3 check and
after 22 now Queen captures Knight ng5
and after Knight character C captures
it's a much better position for black
actually now these bones are actually
protecting the black King white can't
push through this through this so after
Knight captures on see
five the idea behind F captors on e5
Kareena head was actually Knight
captures on d5 sacrificing the Queen on
v3 and the Queen has to be accepted you
don't really you don't really have a way
of not accepting the Queen if you play
something like C capture Sun d5 then
Queen captures would check Knight to g6
blocking and after night h7 black
doesn't have any moves whatsoever
you can't put b6 the Rockies hang you
can't develop the bishop it's a terrible
position for black so after this knife
captors on d5 Medea rava accepted the
Queen Knight captures on b3 now we had
97 with check King to f8 this is the
only move and a captures on b3 a slow
move but enough black can't buy can't
really do anything Bishop captures on if
I was played now rope to h7 Queen to e8
we have Bishop to d2 now preparing
Bishop c3 Bishop captures on b2 and rook
to be one and even rook to c1 was
possible because black can't really
afford to lose the dark square Bishop
Bishop back to f6 we have King to e2 now
b6 preparing to develop the light square
bishop which check rook b2 h 1 now
doubling up on the h-file rook to a6
check King f2 and in this position you
don't have any move to play if you play
a move something like Bishop to g7 you
lose the game instantly rook h8 check
Bishop captures rook after skin g7 and
Bishop to c3 this is checkmate
so after King F - you don't have a move
mama D our what ride Bishop captures and
g5 but here comes a bishop to c3 now
slicing all the way to h8 now mama D our
played Bishop captures on e7 and this is
this is the only position that I wish
that Karina played rook to g7 because
now there's there's no there's no
defense against through up to h8 and
it's game over but the position is so
much better for white that it doesn't
really matter what she plays so she
played D captures on e7
with check you can go King g8 waking g8
you get rook to g7 checkmate
so mama D ro I accepted the poem but now
comes Rock h8 check King to f7 rook H 1
to H seven check King to e6 and now rook
captures Queen King captures and rook
captures an 8 and finally in this
position Zainab mama D Arawa resigned at
the game so yeah I only only want to
remark that rook to g7 would have been
would have been you know more
aesthetically pleasing but this is just
crushing so it doesn't really matter a
wonderful a wonderful victory and a
wonderful creation by polish
international master cutting our shipkov
sky so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Vasily of Macao and deputy directors for
a contribution to my channel thanks a
lot I really appreciate it and thanks
David wada for for sending me this
beautiful game so yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon